all right people we are live on the
YouTube and joining me today is a grad
student at Wilfrid Laurier College who
wasn't even on Twitter a month ago and
is now a major player in the free speech
Wars Lindsay Shepard welcome to the
group and report thank you I think
you're the first guest I usually tell
people right before we start that
there's booze behind you and you're the
first guest I think that was about to a
bottle of some take out the current
predicament you find yourself in yeah
sure
well first off thanks for coming in I'm
glad we were to get out here you came
from the great white north of canada to
be your story is completely crazy and
yet totally obvious to people i think
that have been paying attention to
what's going on sort of at universities
and it free speech in general and
crossing the border by the way of canada
the united states and plenty of other
countries so first off before we get
into the details we're gonna play some
audio and we're gonna read some
statements and all that stuff how are
you I'm doing well it's been a pretty
crazy time and for example earlier this
week I had a six page paper and a
presentation do didn't do it couldn't do
it right I don't have time this has kind
of taken over my life for now but I'm
okay with that
yeah and I'm willing to make sacrifices
yeah well we need people like you in
this fight and I think you kind of got
thrust into this almost almost
accidentally but it's pretty clear to me
that you're willing to be in the fight
and that's sort of what we need so
before we get into the all the specifics
for the people that don't know anything
about you tell me a little bit about
what you study in the first place what
are the things that actually brought you
here in the first place sure so um I'm
doing my Master of Arts in cultural
analysis and social theory but my
bachelor's degree is in communication so
that's why I'm a teaching assistant in
communication yeah alright so we're
gonna play some audio we have two
separate audio parts that I want people
to play there's how long was the whole
chunk of audio about 42 minutes okay so
about 40 minutes so we're gonna play a
piece right now that's about five
minutes and then later with a piece
that's about three minutes I'm sure many
of the people have listened to the whole
thing but we tried to parse out the
parts that I thought were that I thought
were most important but before we play
them why
you record the audio so I got an email
summoning me to the meeting and the
audio is of the meeting that I'm yeah
yeah so actually why don't we why don't
we set it up first so what did you
actually do that caused you to be
summoned to a meeting and again this is
what about six weeks ago or so right yes
it was that November first
so I played about four minutes of a
debate between Jordan Peterson and
another fellow at the University of
Toronto named Nicholas Matt so two two
scholars on a show called the agenda
with Steve Paikin which is just like a
great moderate talk show produced by TV
Ontario which is like a public
broadcaster in Ontario mm-hmm
but it turns out someone was offended
and it all went down from there so yes I
got an email saying that there were some
concerns about the content of my
tutorials okay but then it said the this
was from Professor Ram pukana who was
writing this email yeah I'm asking
someone from the diversity and equity
office to come in to meet with us and I
thought like if they're gonna bring a
diversity and equity official in over
this I need to record this because if if
this ends up being ridiculous winning it
was then I want to have proof that this
is happening man so you really were
tipped off to some of what has been
going on this didn't come as a complete
surprise to you in that case so that's
so a professor so what we're gonna hear
is the professor and the diversity
officer talking to you and how did you
do it by the way I think people would
like to know did you have the was it
your iPhone in your pocket with
something in your pocketbook what do you
actually do it was just my laptop out in
front of me
really did they wonder why your laptop
was right in front of you while you were
having this meeting I said I was taking
notes yeah yeah so there was three
people in the meeting professor Rambo
Kenna and then dr. Herbert Pimlott who's
my program coordinator my master's
program and then the diversity and
equity official is adria Joel and she's
in charge of gendered violence inside
actual assault prevention right and a
couple other things that we should just
clarify the complaint was anonymous
correct so no one so they were saying
someone was offended but no one stepped
forward to say that they were the person
that was offended
and also just to be very clear the piece
that you showed this wasn't about
whether trans people should have rights
or be treated poorly or anything like
that this was about the debate over the
words that we can use related to their
pronouns correctly yeah okay I think
have we set it up properly you feel good
about that
all right so we're going to throw to
about it's gonna be roughly about four
or five minutes of audio here and then
we'll be back with Lindsay in a moment
so if you okay so um we we have to teach
about grammar and in the Pearson book
there was a section about pronouns and
using like gendered language so I wanted
to make it more engaging so what I did
is we were talking about in papers using
a as as like a singular and then we were
also talking about like his and hers and
like how to construct sentences with
that and then to contextualize it I
brought up like a YouTube debate so a
debate with both sides during Peterson
sides and this this fellow named Nicolas
Matt who is also a prophet Youth T okay
and they do have a name of the video um
it was from the agenda with Steve Paikin
okay it was like a YouTube debate it was
one hour long but I showed about five
minutes and then some I mean the
students were we're very interested I
could tell that all of their eyes were
on the screen and after when we had a
debate there were people of all opinions
and like from from what I could see it
was a very friendly debate obviously
this person who had an issue did not
express it to me they just went straight
to whoever I don't I don't really know
what happened so I'm just for some
additional context so you come you can
turn mutti all right no no you fell from
SFU okay so you weren't like one of the
George Peters of the students yeah so
just to give you some context that have
turned theaters and
he is a figure that's basically highly
involved with the with the alt-right he
yes the website rabble media which is an
all right website has been involved in
raising multiple hundreds of thousands
of dollars for his research
it's he has gave a lecture in which he
identified student protesters like by
posting their social media accounts so
that people would bully and and threaten
them online he lectures about basically
like critiquing feminism critiquing
trans rights I'm familiar like I gotta
see
the thing is can you shield people from
those ideas am I supposed to comfort
them and make sure that they are
insulated away from this like is that
what the point of this is because to me
that is so against what a university is
about so against it I was not taking
sides I was presenting both arguments so
the thing is about this is if you're
presenting something like this it you
have to think about the kind of teaching
climate that you're creating and this is
actually these arguments are counter to
the Canadian Human Rights Code ever
since then you know that you talked
about
c16 ever since this past it is
discriminatory to be targeting someone
due to their gender identity or gender
expression so bringing something like
that up and class not critically and I
understand that you're trying to like it
was critical why I introduced it
critically how so like I said like I
said I it was in the spirit of debate
okay in the spirit of the debate is
slightly different than being like okay
this is this is like a problematic idea
that we won make me wanna unpack but
that's taking sides like it
taking sides for me to be like oh look
at this guy like everything that comes
out his mouth is BS but we're gonna
watch anyway okay so I understand the
position they are coming from and your
positionality but the reality is that it
is created a toxic climate or some of
the students hey you know I mean it's
great oh how many okay one yeah it might
be I know I have no concept of like how
many people complain like what their
complaint was you haven't showed me the
complaint yes I understand that this is
upsetting but there's also confidential
at comfy and confidentiality matters the
number of people is special
yes okay is one or multiple students who
have come forward saying that this is
something that they were concerned about
it and that it means I'm not comfortable
if this is for example a trans student
this is basically debating whether or
not a trans student should have rights
within one of their classes and that's
not something that is really acceptable
in the context of the kind of learning
environment that we're trying to create
it would be the equivalent of debating
whether or not you know a student of
color should have rights or should be
allowed to be married
do you see word like how this is not
it's not something like that's
intellectually neutral that is kind of
up for debate this is I mean this is the
Charter of Rights but it is that's for
debate but I mean you're perfectly
welcome your own opinions but when
you're bringing it into the context of
the classroom that can become
problematic and that can become
something that is that creates an unsafe
learning environment for students but
when they leave the university they're
gonna be exposed to these ideas so I
don't see how I'm doing a disservice to
the class by exposing them to ideas that
are really out there and I'm sorry I'm
crying I'm stressed out because this to
me is so wrong okay so that is just
about a five minute portion of the forty
two minute video I just want to be very
very clear before I give this back to
Lindsay here
every thing that you heard that
professors say is complete drivel I was
making notes while we did it we were
kind of shaking our our heads together
first off let's just talk about Peterson
for a second Peterson is highly involved
with the alt-right rebel media company
out of Canada which is owned by Ezra
Levant a Jew is part of the alt-right
what what did that stay like did that
even mean anything to you when he said
that actually I shake my head when he
says it and that's why he says yes after
cuz I was I'm still under the impression
he's not involved with the alt-right
yeah and I mean interestingly now rebel
media which was referenced they've
interviewed me and that's how I've now
become also associated I met Azra like
two weeks ago at an event in Florida and
he's a completely nice guy I don't know
all of his politics about everything but
the guy couldn't be nicer just silliness
all right so you're creating a hostile
teaching climate by presenting ideas
yeah what are we supposed to make of
this I mean when he was saying these
things you obviously you were getting
emotional but did you want to fight back
more like you were really kind of taking
it and I think you you stood your ground
where you felt you had to but did you
really want to push back on that like
creating a hostile teaching environment
you did exactly what a teacher is
supposed to do I mean it's almost like
my mind just doesn't work the way that
theirs does that's what I was kind of
realizing is like they're making these
huge stretches that like talking about
they in the singular is tantamount to
debating someone's humanity in addition
to debating like whether a student of
color has rights I mean they're just
making these huge stretches and I my
mind doesn't work that way and I'm just
you know I'm more reasonable reasonable
about things and yeah so then he
referenced C 16 which is this new
I guess directive the human rights the
Canadian Human Rights Code this is what
put Jordan Peterson on the map a year
ago when he basically in effect but
correct me if I'm wrong there and it's
basically he said I have no problem with
trans people but you meaning the
government can't tell me what labels to
use or what words come out of my mouth
we'll come from my mind and that's all
so this Peterson was proven right here I
mean that's what I kept thinking the
entire time is that Peterson was right
he was warning about this a year ago and
now look how it has been turned on to
someone like you yes and even people who
don't agree with professor Peterson are
angry that professor Rambo kind of used
that argument because now it's kind of
proven him right right which is a really
interesting the other line that really
got me was he said that this is like
debating whether a trans student has
rights just to be very clear what are
your feelings on trans people and the
rights that they should be afforded I
believe they should have all the rights
they you know everyone should have I
have no problem with trans people and
like I it's so strange because I'm just
such an empathetic and kind person and
so to to suddenly be transphobic it's
like wow like what do you call the
people who are actually transphobic then
because I'm just so okay with it right
which is the irony of what they do in
general then they call someone like you
a transfer band then they call someone
like you and all right and what it does
is it makes it seem like the all right
or being a transfer that this is must be
the widest tent ever because they take
they take everybody in there so ok so
you record this thing I assume it when
worse than you anticipated like did you
really think I mean that you recorded it
so you must have you know sort of guess
what was gonna happen what did you do
right after that um right after that I
sent it to media outlets just right
after I was really not happy with the
way it went
especially how they were accusing me of
violating this policy in that law and
you know one of the most frustrating
things to me though was that I didn't
get to know what the complaint even said
and also this is not a formal complaint
that went through any kind of you know
university body this was from what I
assume an email to the professor that
said I'm unhappy and at this point we
don't even know if that actually exists
correctly we have no indication whether
it was as he said it was one or many or
something to that effect we don't even
know that even one existed this may have
come from them we just simply don't know
we don't know was there any other
recourse you know I've heard some people
say well she went right to the media was
there any other recourse you think you
could have taken at the University or
did you feel you had exhausted that
because this was there this was the
diversity people yeah and and the
diversity and equity people control a
lot more than we might realize I think
and just seeing the president of the
university's response to all this what
would have been the point of going to
her I mean look at how she's reacting
she's she's publicly made it clear that
like she's not willing to support what I
did yeah she's not willing to support my
stance and really she which is a stance
for freedom of inquiry which is a stands
for freedom of speech
it's a stands for actual education
mm-hmm not willing staff ready of those
things exactly yeah we should read some
of the Vice Chancellors statement what
do you think all right so I'm gonna read
some of this we're gonna we're gonna
throw it up after listening to this
recording an apology is in order I
should say this is Vice Chancellor
Deborah McClatchy after listening to
this recording an apology is in order
the conversation I heard does not
reflect the values and practices to
which Laurier aspires I'm sorry it
occurred in the way that it did and I
regret the impact it had on Lindsey
Shepherd the university is committed to
ensuring that the vitally important role
of teaching assistants supports an
enriched learning environment for all
students let me be clear by stating that
Laurier is committed to the abiding
principles of freedom of speech and
freedom of expression giving life to
these principles while respecting
fundamentally important human rights and
our institutional values of diversity
and inclusion is not a simple matter the
intense media interest points to a
highly polarizing and very complicated
set of issues that is affecting
universities across the Democratic world
the polarizing nature of the current
debate does not do justice to the
complexity of issues so that statement
sounds pretty good basically right does
that sound there's a little bit of I can
see where there's a little bit of a
slide in that but pretty good pretty
good but I mean at the start there it
was you know I'm sorry for the way the
meeting occurred in the way that it did
and you know what I get from that is I'm
sorry it was like three on one I'm sorry
you had no
representation I'm sorry that they they
weren't nicer to you but I'll just be on
it's like when I was in that meeting I
didn't feel like I needed anybody I
didn't particularly feel bullied either
which is kind of interesting because
that's a point that so many people bring
up is like she was bullied like this is
three-on-one this is not fair this is
like basically harassment so it's kind
of interesting to me that like I
actually like never felt that way
because all that really mattered to me
was the content of what they were saying
which was that like there's only one
brand of acceptable ideas here and
because you're not promoting that you're
in trouble
yeah so the inherent conflict here is
that the President and the Vice
Chancellor is sort of saying different
things right I mean they're based the
Vice Chancellor in this statement is
basically saying we stand by Lindsay the
president is sort of saying that these
are at the idea that diversity and
inclusion supersede well the President
and Vice Chancellor at the same person
it's Deborah McLeod Shay's both
positions oh yeah
well that changes everything for me I
suppose well then okay so then what well
then what does that prove other than
that I'm confused about this um yeah I
mean I've been she also did an interview
with Steve Paikin yeah and remember that
clip I showed is from the agenda with
Steve Paikin so just a couple days ago I
think she was on the agenda with Steve
Paikin and he kept asking her like did
Lindsay do anything wrong and you know
she she wouldn't give a clear answer
yeah but because her argument would have
to be that by c16 that show shouldn't
even be allowed to be on television then
right I mean that that topic should not
be discussed exactly so and that's just
quite ludicrous oh yeah you you
mentioned bullying I've seen a couple
articles now written by apparently
legitimate organizations in Canada that
you're the bully you're the bully what
was the one just a day or two ago that
you're bullying these students and using
your white privilege what are what are
some of the things you've been called by
the way after this it's pretty legit
people I bullied the students but also I
bullied professor Rambo Khanna because
he's a person of color and I'm white and
so I used my white woman tears to
overstep my boundaries and
try to step all over his job just
because he's a racialized body yeah as
they say which is again such a stretch
that it's like I can't even process how
you think that way
yeah and you've been called alright and
all the rest of it right I mean that
that's just coming did you ever think
that you were gonna have to get on
Twitter because it's sounding like this
first off the fact that you weren't on
Twitter before this is the most
wonderful thing I've ever heard and
that's the set the truly sad part to me
of all of this is that you now have to
be subjected to Twitter um I've actually
kind of been enjoying Twitter every what
I do is it at first yeah it is nice to
address things just in my own words
which was why I made it and also there
was just kind of the dynamic of how I
started a Twitter out of all this but
professor Rambo kind of took his Twitter
offline professor Herbert pin wat hid
his Twitter and then adrià Joe will the
diversity and equity person is just
nowhere to be found - yeah throughout
all of us for the past month nowhere to
be found
really yeah I mean that's that's
fascinating I should address that my
confusion over the President and the
Vice Chancellor because the way you
describe the president's words actually
sounded slightly different than this
statement which which just shows you
that they're trying to play both both
sides of everything you know and they
kind of have to if you know coming from
the perspective of needing student
tuition dollars they do have to try to
play to both because students do expect
to kind of be coddled now it's how
they're kind of raised yeah so you know
I get it from that perspective but of
course it's not my principle yeah
principle is you have to stand by
academic freedom freedom of expression
all right well speaking of dollars let's
throw to this second audio clip which is
about two or three minutes and I thought
was particularly interesting
do you understand how what happened was
contrary to certain intervals of the
policy their genders its genders and
sexual violence policy like do you
understand how but sorry what did I
violate in that policy
um so gender-based violence
transphobia in that policy causing harm
to trans students by bringing their
identity as invalid or their pronouns as
invalid or something essentially invalid
so I caused part which is under the
Ontario Human Rights Code it protected
thing and also something that Laurier
called as the value okay so by proxy me
showing you the video I'm transphobic
and I caused harm to violence so be it
like I can't do anything to control that
okay so that's not something that you
have an issue with the fact that that
happened like I mean I'm just I know
that I know in my heart and I know I
expressed you the class yeah I'm not
transphobic and if any of them I don't
know
again I don't know what they said but I
made my I don't think I gave away any
kind of political position of mine I
remained very neutral and that's kind of
the problem is that if you're framing
something that is like this like just to
give you the example of like in lecture
I also showed something that was from
like a member of the alright were you
there for the flavor gums unlimited
video comment yeah 3d printing etc so
this is someone who also has like a site
like the ones that fund Jordan Pederson
like patreon with a bucket about writing
white supremacist website that basically
uses that gets funding for these
projects if they get kicked off of
things like like IndieGoGo etc but I
framed it by saying those kinds of
things by actually bringing out the the
critical perspective to just present
information like this
neutrally it can help cultivate an
environment where these these kinds of
opinions like all bright opinions white
supremacist opinions anti trends
opinions anti-gay opinions anti-women
misogynist pinions where those can feel
like it's a space where those kinds of
opinions can be nurtured and created and
that's the kind of the frame on why some
kinds of content we would use in class
and some wouldn't use or we would only
use those for upper your classes or grad
students like for example in one of your
classes it might be appropriate to watch
a white supremacist like recruitment
video something that Richard Spencer has
done because there's students with more
critical faculties that have been
exposed to more things that have had
more time to come process these are very
young students and something of that
nature is not appropriate to that age of
student because they don't eighteen yes
adults yes but they're very young adults
they don't have the the the critical
toolkit to be able to take it apart yet
this is one of the things that we're
teaching them and so this is this is why
it becomes something that has to be done
with a bit more care I get what you mean
about streaming it like I remember when
you when you talked about the 3d
printing of the guns and how you said it
was problematic and like in retrospect
yeah should have used that word
problematic thought that would have been
a good word to frame it that's good that
you acknowledge that especially since
you're saying that you know this is not
something that you agree with this is
not something that you're trying to to
promote it's just that you're trying to
open up the debate but the problem is
that that particular debate is about
whether trans people are people or not
does that make sense um it's a it's a
language issue and you can extend it to
whether you want to
Senate personhood or not and I didn't
present that argument I did present the
argument that by denying people their
pronouns you are denying their dignity
man I mean that guy really should not be
allowed at a university or any place of
higher education anywhere I mean every
literally everything he said there was
was pure drivel the debate is whether
trans people are people that has nothing
to do with the debate it has nothing to
do with the debate that you brought up
or do anything to do with the debate
that Jordan Peterson brought up but you
conceded a little ground there you said
I should have said it was problematic
did you feel that that all gave you a
little bit of an out with him or
something yeah I don't even know if I
stand by that statement um people have
asked me like do i rescind that like
what I say was problematic I don't know
yeah probably not
but you know when you're in a meeting
like that like you you just have to you
say things yeah the reason that I threw
to it by saying speaking of money is
because I thought it was interesting
that then he decided to go after patreon
because my show is funded by patreon the
reason we were able to fly you here and
put you in a hotel is because of my
patrons that that fund this these are
not racists and bigots most of them are
are sort of disaffected lefties and
we've got some conservatives and my
audience is all over this I really don't
even know where my audience is but I
thought that was sort of interesting
because I've seen that pop up lately
that they want to go after the money
sources for all of these people and
scare you to ever try to crowdfund now
because you what if for whatever you
want to do in the rest of your life you
could probably crowd fund because people
admire your courage what did you make of
him going after sites like that I'd
never heard of patreon I wasn't very
involved with like internet culture yeah
or anything so yeah I'd actually never
heard of it I thought he said hey Treon
yeah well there is a site called hey
tree on which is where for people that
have been booted off of patreon for
certain political views they created
another site called hey tree on which is
that's actually where more of the
alright for whatever the alright is that
seems to be where their people go what
did you think about this thing about age
which I thought was interesting you said
18 as an adult and he basically was
saying well they're they're young adults
we have to wait till they're older to
teach them these ideas
except he's the very person that's gonna
insulate them from the idea so you don't
magically your brain doesn't magically
just learn more by the time you're 21 if
you've been insulated the whole time
right yeah I think it's just a really
unfair position and to take because my
students like in that class they were so
mature and intelligent and they had
really great things to say so yeah I
think it's kind of insulting to them to
suggest that they can't handle this yeah
I know I've always been a person who has
never liked to have been infantilized or
like I don't like it when people
condescend me and so I treat people with
that same respect but I find it
condescending to say that you know you
can't handle an idea even though you're
in a university and you got into a
university right by the way I think it
was sort of well not sort of it was
extremely kind of sending the way he
said well when he showed that video for
the class that you were in about the
guns he did it the right way he did it
the right way but what you did by just
presenting things that was wrong I mean
that that's the reverse of teaching yeah
oh it's it's really kind of good what's
it been like for you on campus since
then you were telling me right before we
started a little bit about that yeah um
I found out that a lot of people just
don't like what I did they don't like
that I showed that video clip in class
do you think they really grasped what
actually you showed do you think they
really understand the issues or they're
just going off of what they're hearing
and she's a transfer band blah blah blah
maybe both and you know the thing is
like now I'm regarded with a lot of
suspicion mm-hmm and people have told me
that they're afraid that I'm recording
every encounter with them like don't
worry we're not recording this yeah
and so I'm yes I'm regarded with
suspicion are people avoiding you like
when you go onto campus like you can
tell people there and the thing is like
and you know maybe it is awkward for my
classmates like my graduate classmates
and that's fine it might be weird for
them but they don't even try to talk to
me about it
at all but when I go on their social
media accounts they're liking all these
comments that disparage me
or mock me or something and it's like
wow like we sit across from a table with
each other and you can't even bring up
these things with me in person you avoid
eye contact with me yet I look at your
social media and it's all about me yeah
it's such intellectual cowardice I don't
know if you happen to see a little
exchange that Jordan Peterson had
earlier in the week with this guy I
think his name is IRA Wells who wrote a
really awful I would argue libel this
article about Jordan Jordan calls him
out on Twitter says debate me I offered
to host the debate I would do I'll go to
Canada to do it or we can do it right
here whatever they want to do the guy
tweets out yes he'll do the debate and
then in a private email exchange says he
doesn't want to do it anymore and now is
declined and it's like this is what you
all do you say all these things behind
the comforts of your computer but then
in reality we'll never defend your ideas
are you getting any support in quarters
that you didn't expect yeah I mean even
though I am treated a bit weirdly in my
classes like I am getting tons of
support yeah a lot of professors is a
private or public a bit of both yeah
I've gotten hundreds of messages for
sure and a lot like the majority are
from you know grad students students
professors and you know also just
members of the general public who are
really dismayed that this is the state
of education especially when a lot of
people bring up like their tax dollars
are going towards this - yeah it's
interesting because right before we
started I was mentioning Brett Weinstein
who I know you're familiar with in the
whole situation at Evergreen and
Evergreen is considered one of if not V
leftists most left schools in America
and you were saying that Laurier
basically is one of the most left
schools in Canada yes
but the thing is so you so you would
think by standard logic you would think
oh these would be the most places of
most tolerance where trans people would
be most accepted where racial minorities
will be most accepted in all this and
yet the narrative is now suddenly that
they're all under attack at these
schools yeah there's a lot of
homogeneity with the ideology of
Canadian universities though there's
some
called the campus freedom index and it
talks about you know freedom of speech
on campus and no Canadian schools do
particularly well at all
I know Wilfred Laurier has across the
four criteria I believe just even s Wow
yeah that's incredible so I want to read
a statement the the Laurier rainbow
centre which is the LGBTQ do I need any
other letters now I know something
happen in Canada you need a couple extra
letters yeah there's there's also
two-spirited oh yeah I saw a two-spirit
is in there now - what do we know what
that is
it's like exclusively for indigenous
people who identify as like male and
female simultaneously
yes well the rainbow Center issued a
statement which I am going to read I
thought there's so much richness in this
dear Laurier community in the face of
recent media attention we feel it is our
responsibility to speak out against the
climate of transphobia that is being
fostered at Laurier the university
silence on these issues has Foss has
allowed for a one-sided perspective to
be cultivated in the media that is
entirely disconnected from the
experiences of trans people we speak now
as a collective of queer and trans
students asking you to engage critically
with the media you read and to hold our
community with care on Friday November
10th an article was published in the
National Post that disparaged the
university's response to a situation
that emerged in a first-year
communications course we are obligated
to uphold the confidentiality of parties
and therefore are unable to comment
directly on the situation that
instigated this article we can however
speak to the ways which this article and
the dozens that have been published
since our defending and perpetuating
transphobic beliefs and attitudes under
the banner of freedom of speech the news
media have advanced a critique of
institutional practices aimed at
increasing inclusivity and challenging
oppression the always present but often
unnamed other at the center of these
critiques are the trans and non-binary
individuals who these institutional
practices would support we must
understand the ways in which these
attacks on the PC culture of the
university are in actuality attacks on
the needs of trans people that these
critics do not support the discourse of
freedom of speech is being used for
hover over the underlying reality of
transphobia that is so deeply ingrained
in our contemporary political context
ironically these discourses seem intent
on silencing those who speak out against
the systemic violence perpetrated
against trans people while propagating a
far-right ideology in fact recent
empirical studies conducted by white and
Crandall in 2017 have shown that freedom
of speech endorsement is prej is
predicted by underlying prejudicial
attitudes I mean again every word of
this is just nonsense so let's just try
to unpack some of this here what what
violence our trans people subjected to
at Wilfrid Laurier is there any evidence
of systemic violence meaning it's coming
from the University and if it is that
has nothing to do with a grad student
showing the video yeah so like on top of
this there was a petition and letter
launched by about 59 faculty members so
professors who are saying that there's
just a severe harassment problem of
trans people now on campus and they're
at AU meeting now meaning since
apparently yes and their their evidence
is rants on their work voicemails okay
and some emails and have any of these
been released publicly no no again
nothing in public no and as a reporter
said to me as we were talking about this
the other day like for her that's just a
usual Tuesday yeah like if you're
putting out there yeah yeah people are
not going to respond so nicely and
unfortunately you know why I've been
critiquing the rainbow Center is they're
making themselves they're creating this
false binary of like that to be LGBTQ is
to be antithetical to free speech and
freedom of expression which is just
nonsense and I've gotten a lot of
letters actually from trans people who
say like we don't agree with what this
rainbow Center is doing they don't speak
for us yeah I'm so glad you said that so
this is sync ly because I think you're
totally right they're making it sound
like if you are not making it sound this
is what they're saying
the discourse of freedom of speech is
being used to cover over the underlying
reality of transphobia it's so deeply
ingrained in our contemporary political
context so that the implication is that
if you exercise free speech you are
somehow a bigot yeah and which then can
be applied across the board anywhere
right and it's not as if they haven't
benefited from free speech of course
they have and you know when I was
speaking at a free speech rally on
Friday a week ago they had a counter
protest who counter protests free speech
and and their argument was that there
would defend their right to do it yeah
exactly yeah their argument is they're
being silenced and they've this has been
their continuous narrative as they're
being silenced by media they're being
silenced but they're in the news almost
as much as I am like you know it started
to become actually like kind of more
about them yeah so I disagree that
they're being silenced do you know of
any issues with trans people at Wilfried
before this I'm not to say there of
course there's gonna be some prejudicial
people and there's gonna be somebody
that doesn't like you because you're a
woman or you're white and there's gonna
be something that doesn't like a black
person or a Muslim person or whatever
else but was I mean they're talking
about this they're saying this is
systemic this stuff now you're saying
since your thing there's been some
voicemails which we don't know where
they come from yeah I'm I'm maybe there
is like I'm probably systemic is the
word violence systemic where are we here
they include it I'll find it in a second
I mean even in that meeting they did
bring up you know like trans suicide
rates as if I was somehow contributing
to that yeah and yes so I mean I think
you know I don't deny that trans people
do experience violence but I don't think
they're going about this the right way
and you're just gonna make people have
resentment towards you if you're going
to act this way and act as if to be
trans
to be against free speech it just
doesn't make sense yeah what's your
general political leanings because as I
mentioned earlier you you said in in
this in the original audio I don't think
it was in the portion we played and
you've said to me you don't agree with
everything jordan peterson says i find
that to be like the funniest comment
that people have to say now about
everybody anytime you say you like
somebody yet say but i don't agree with
everything they say we're just generally
it's a pretty obvious statement right i
mean is there anyone on earth you agree
with 100% no yeah exactly and you know
can't we just like someone because they
have interesting perspectives like
that's my thing is i'm just i'm i like
interesting people and why can't we talk
about what they're putting out there
it's so yeah what would you say your
general political beliefs are at i don't
need to know every specific everything
but before this because now with people
google you i mean they're gonna just see
all this horrible stuff so what were
your beliefs before this um i consider
myself a left-leaning um and I kind of
still do but also I've also been tempted
by the idea of like maybe I should just
like join the right there being so
welcoming to me yeah but what do you
make of that I mean it's kind of funny I
mean I can see it at you like it's kind
of funny but to me this is like you're
sort of having your what everyone calls
the red pill moment where it's like the
rubbers meeting the road with your life
right now you know and I've seen this
happen so many times and I've seen it
happen to myself where it's like man
let's put it this way are you getting
any backing from people on the left yeah
so some private backing and things like
that but I mean your public defenders
basically have all been you know these
alright it's sometimes it's hard to tell
right and it's it's become so muddied
because yeah if leftism and you maybe
you know yeah leftism is about silencing
and suppressing and censorship and like
no I don't want to be associated values
what is left is Amin to you know like
when you say I consider myself mostly on
the right sorry on the left yeah so like
for example like my principle value is
like protecting the environment
right um I believe in I like Canada's
health care system so like socialized
medicine mm-hmm you know and I consider
myself a feminist too and so you know
it's it's interesting that I can be in
agreement with all those things but they
still think I'm a terrible yeah where
does the feminism piece fit into this
because I'm gonna guess that the
feminist community the general feminists
can be ain't gonna be having a lot of
what you're serving up these days yeah I
mean it's yeah I I kind of almost
understand some resentment to feminism
now before I thought like yeah those
people just don't get it but now I'm
kind of seeing why there's resistance
towards feminism and it's because of
this kind of censorship stuff and it's
because of you know making males out to
be like devious people you know that's
just not helpful that's not productive
for society so you know that's something
that I've come to realize now is kind of
understanding where that resistance come
from yeah so you're sort of going
through it right now like you're kind of
really challenging all of your beliefs
yeah yeah it's actually kind of cool in
a way right like I know it's kind of
exhausting probably but yeah yeah um but
I I like learning about other people's
perspectives and even for example a lot
of my supporters throughout all this
have been religious people and I'm not
religious but I've kind of realized that
like their free speech is like a huge
value to religious people for you know
many different reasons so I'm you know
I'm finding myself kind of almost allied
with people who you know normally maybe
I wouldn't have been but that's what I
think is great because it's productive
to understanding other people in society
yeah I mean I can't tell you how much I
truly hear you and I and I think that so
much of my audience can truly hear you
because I think a lot of them are going
through this sort of same thing what
about friends and family support support
or not support
your family are they supportive of
everything you're doing yes yeah yeah
yes and also my friends are as well yeah
have you had any friends that have given
you the really oh I hate to tell you but
that's coming next but you're gonna get
a lot of new friends at the same time I
mean that that's truly what's gonna
happen here has any of this affected
sort of what do you what what you want
to do in your future if I was to ask you
six weeks ago what you wanted to to be
when you grow up and you're out of
school um I didn't know that and I still
don't know now yeah yeah but I suspect
this will probably change things yeah
yeah
because now I've kind of made it clear
that I'm not willing to play along with
the political correctness stuff and you
know once you take that position there's
a lot of people who regard you as like
kind of a dangerous person but I think
I'm not interested in in a society that
is so stifling and and feels like they
need to censor themselves around other
people it's just it's it's almost even
just kind of bland really bland and it's
it's also fake because a lot of people
will play the game around other people
and they'll go along with the political
correctness stuff but when they go home
they're their true colors like they're
they make fun of things and they grumble
about the political correctness so it's
also just fake yeah
well that sort of goes to the virtue
signaling you were talking about before
where it's like in your classes these
kids these students sorry will sit
across from you and say nothing but then
they'll go online and publicly you know
because they want the cred they'll throw
you under the bus or say all these awful
things about you but they never have the
guts to sit across from you and do it
right then in there and maybe that's
also just a result of is that like the
culture we live in now you know like
people are more passive aggressive
because they can say stuff online
yeah so I saw you got into a little
thing on Twitter where someone was
calling you I guess it was who was the
the girl I'm sorry I don't remember um I
believe her name is a detect out hurry
yeah okay so she wrote an article I
think on medium.com basically I mean she
was in effect calling you white national
right what were some of the exact words
it was that article but just also heard
tweets from you know almost from the day
I started my Twitter just yeah I'm I
want a white ethno state I have you know
I'm a crying white girl have you ever
called for a white ethno state no you
just want to get that out there you know
yeah and you know I so for my two first
years of university I was also in this
kind of camp of ideas is that white
people are racist no matter what like I
bought into that idea
mm-hm and you know I bought into the
idea that it's just a power structure
there's no such thing as reverse racism
but I started to question that and I
started to see that it's actually like
hurtful what they say and I don't
tolerate any kind of racial harassment
because what she's doing is racial
harassment yeah and it shouldn't be
tolerable for any race what's
interesting is so as someone that was in
that line of thinking pretty recently
did you think you were racist because if
the idea is white people are racist by
definition by the color of their skin
their immutable characteristic of
whiteness that they're racist meanwhile
you're white while having those thoughts
did you automatically have to think you
were inherently racist I definitely had
like struggles with the white guilt you
know and just like always having to be
aware of cultural appropriation and that
kind of stuff but eventually I just I
just rejected it because it just you
know I just don't agree intellectually
where these ideas come from you know I'm
it gets the point like in one of my
classes just a couple weeks ago someone
said he he was kind of making a comment
about how white people who eat quinoa
are racist because then the people who
farm it can't eat it and that's just
kind of the thinking now and I just yeah
I like you know I like quinoa too high
in protein
I thought a little garlic I guess we're
Nazis now the Nazis did love quinoa I
think that's the main takeaway from this
whole thing so this girl writes this
piece about you and basically you sent
out a tweet saying that in effect what
she was doing was liable and then I saw
a little bit of pushback people saying
wait a minute the new free speech
absolutist is now calling something
libel which i think is so fascinating to
me because libel is a law there are
libel laws I am a free speech absolutist
but I do believe in the libel laws I
have no problem with them whatsoever
if you malign someone to destroy them
which by calling people white
supremacist and Nazis you're these days
you're calling for violence because a
lot of the same people will say you can
punch a Nazi too so they're actually
calling for violence towards you but did
you struggle with that a little bit when
you were sending that tweet because I've
done the same thing too by the way and I
got [ __ ] for it and I don't regret it um
well I think what she's doing is trying
to ruin my reputation
yeah and associate me with all these
things and which I'm so clearly not and
what really troubles me about her
personally is that as she's a PhD
student yeah at another University in
Ontario from from what I can see on her
profile and actually a lot of the hate
I've been getting is from PhD students
at you know largely universities in
Ontario and it's just so troubling
because those people are going to become
professors yeah and those people are
gonna have serious power over the way
that we think and so if they're just
literally of the idea that there's a
correct way to think those people should
not be in positions where they're
leading young thinkers right absolutely
not and especially someone like her who
is you know despite my struggle to say
this but like she's a racist basically
she's racist against white people I'm
you know cuz now I'm starting to think
okay I think you can be racist against
white people
yeah even though I I was taught in
university that if that doesn't exist
I'm it does doesn't it well because it's
so inherently racist because what she's
basically saying was that if you said
the exact same things that you say now
but you weren't
white that it wouldn't be racist right
that ain't right
but you know what we'll do in the in in
honor of open inquiry edita that's her
name I will gladly invite her here I'll
find I'll find out reach out there I
will find her and welcome her here to
sit down with you again I'll gladly fly
you both out I suspect she's probably
not going to do it but I gladly will do
it and I will be as neutral as I
possibly can be
I'd also I know we have to cut this
short because you're heading back to
Toronto now but I'd love to get you in
here with Jordan sometime and you can to
Jordan's face I know you did Crowder
with him last night over Skype but you
can talk to him about the issues that
you might have differences with him and
I think he would love to do that and I'm
more than anything else I just want to
thank you for doing this because we need
people brave decent people like you to
be doing this and and I think that's why
you're getting the reaction that you're
getting it's like we keep looking for
other heroes because there's so many bad
actors these days and and I genuinely
thank you for taking the time and I wish
you luck on everything you're doing
thank you all right guys so for more on
Lindsay you can follow her on Twitter at
new world hominin and normally we do
patreon questions after this we're not
doing it today because Lindsay does have
to jump on a flight and get back to
Canada but I do want to give a special
shout out to all our patrons who make
shows like this happened because we were
able to fly Lindsay yeah we put her up
in a hotel I can't even buy you lunch
though because you got to get out of
here quick but I'll find something here
that I can give you all right guys
thanks for watching and again it's new
world hominin on Twitter